by Arjun now I don't see a way how he  can keep up dealing with this pressure  and this threat yeah I think it just  resigns I mean there is just nothing to  be done I mean Magnus just has destroyed  argument and here we see that how big  psychologist Magnus is yeah that he  somehow sensed correctly that uh it's  the first game I should just uh get  Arjun out of his comfort zone yet don't  play anything that he might expect and  we have seen lately actually Magnus was  toying a lot with uh with playing the  the Beards but still I don't think that  Arjun could have expected because piets  always comes as a surprise yeah like it  it almost feels like the your opponent  underestimates you yeah that he's ready  to willing to take the risk of uh going  for something yeah navitea sacrifice the  Queen the only problem is that he  doesn't get enough and in fact not only  does not get enough yeah he needs to  design and he designed all right and  that's it Magnus wins the best